PROFESSOR: So now let's
talk about viruses,
which is our main focus
in these lectures.
So viruses are very
different from bacteria,
because they are pathogens which
infect the cells of your body.
And so they themselves are
not large cellular organisms,
but in fact have a
different biology.
So they consist
of virions, which
are a capsid form of the virus,
which contains a strand of RNA,
which is some genetic material
that, when this capsid is then
integrated into the host cell,
the RNA can basically activate
to infect that cell, and also
replicate itself and make
some more virions, which
can spread out and infect
additional cells.
So the basic entity that
we're worried about here
is really a small object, which
is often shaped like a sphere,
or maybe it's an
ellipsoid, the virion.
And it's much, much smaller.
So the typical size is
really on the order --
the radius, let's say -- is on
the order of 100 nanometers.
So that is 0.1 micron or less,
so much smaller than even
the smallest aerosol droplets
that we can easily observe.
So they're extremely tiny.
There's a couple examples
we can think about,
which are famous examples.
So one class of viruses
cause the disease measles.
And measles has a virus
shape, as you can see here,
which is not quite spherical but
usually a little bit elongated,
like an ellipsoid,
and has a typical size
of 100 to 300
nanometers in diameter.
So measles is still a
very active disease,
which we have been
controlling for a long time
with vaccinations.
But despite that, there
were still, in 2018,
114,000 deaths
worldwide from measles.
And it's estimated that in
the eight years before that --
actually, in the 20 years
before that, excuse me --
that the vaccine has saved
around 23 million lives that
would be lost otherwise
if this virus were
allowed to propagate.
And measles -- it is
known to be airborne.
So this is the classic example
of an airborne transmission.
It's been studied
by, for example,
Riley in the 1970s,
who demonstrated
measles transmission in
schools and in other settings.
And from our perspective,
in this lecture,
it's not surprising.
These viruses or
virions are so small,
they can be contained in
the smallest droplets, which
are easily present
in the air for hours,
and so they are
not settling out.
So what's of much more
interest to us today
is the family of coronaviruses.
So coronaviruses look
very similar to this one,
but they have these
proteins that stick out,
which we've all
seen, that look a bit
like a crown, or a corona.
And they still have
an RNA on the inside.
And there's lots of different
human coronaviruses.
So there are the standard
human coronaviruses,
which cause the common cold.
And there are four typical
human coronaviruses
that cause common colds
that we all experience,
and more serious pneumonias,
but generally not
life-threatening illnesses.
But there are variations of the
coronavirus mutations, which
are constantly coming
into contact with humans
and can cause much
more serious diseases.
So in recent memory, we've had
the Severe Acute Respiratory
Syndrome coronavirus.
And there was a big outbreak,
reasonably big outbreak
around 2003, that
started also in China.
And it infected around 8,000
people, and about 800 died.
So It was a fairly lethal
disease, about 10% mortality,
but fortunately, it
didn't spread too widely.
More recently, there was
the Middle East Respiratory
Syndrome coronavirus,
which was in 2012.
And this led, over the couple
of years after that as well,
to around 2,500 cases
and around 850 deaths.
So again, an outbreak that
was potentially very serious
but remained controlled and
was primarily in Saudi Arabia.
And then we come to SARS-CoV-2,
which, we all know the story.
So this is the
novel coronavirus,
which appeared in Wuhan,
China, in December 2019,
and then led to the
present global pandemic,
which so far has claimed
almost a million deaths.
So as of today, which
is September 24,
it's around 976,000
deaths worldwide.
And the confirmed cases are
currently at about 3.8 million,
which is a reasonable fraction
of the world's population,
around 7 billion.
So what we can
understand from all this
is that these are
very small objects.
They cannot swim.
And so they are just sort
of floating in droplets.
And so, of course, they
can be in small droplets.
And as we'll discussed
next, you can
imagine that they're
actually more
infectious in those
small droplets,
because they can more easily get
out and reach host cells when
they're transmitted.
Moreover, small
droplets are much easier
to get deep into your
respiratory system,
into the smallest
cavities of your lungs,
where there's a high surface
area for that interaction
to take place.